- Hey, guys, it's Justine,
and today, we have one of
the brand new iPad minis
that were just announced.
I've had a few of these over the years
and it was always one
of my favorite devices
because of its size.
I've been traveling a
lot for about 10 years,
so, having something that is portable
and easy to take with me,
I mean, now, I mostly use my phone.
But for people who don't have phones
or for scenarios like smart homes
or people that are in restaurants
that are now switching to iPads,
there are so many other
scenarios for this thing
than just a media device.
Obviously, it is an
incredible media device.
But the iPad mini has a bunch of updates
from the previous version.
I honestly thought that Apple
forgot about the iPad mini
until recently, it has made its revival
and it is here and we're
gonna check it out.
This is the 256-gig WiFi
and cellular version.
Obviously, they have it in both models
if you do just want a WiFi version.
This is the Silver version.
It also comes in a Space
Gray and the Rose Gold.
It's still exciting every time
even if I know what is inside the box.
So, the first thing
that you're gonna notice
is yes, it does have that
same look as the old models.
What is so shocking to me
is if Apple released this
as a phone next year,
I would not even, I would
be like, all right, cool.
I wouldn't even think twice.
Like, this is a realistic size
that I feel like we would be
okay with if this was a phone.
I wouldn't even be surprised.
Like, hello?
I will take your call, Justine here.
I think most people would be more shocked
that I answered my phone.
I hardly ever talk on the phone.
Most of the time, I'm texting
or, you can find me on Twitter.
Okay, we've got our iPad.
One thing that I think that
you guys are gonna notice
and I saw a lot of people
talking about online,
is this is the same
design as the old version.
So the original iPad,
like, not much has
changed as far as looks.
It sill has our Touch ID.
Let's see what else is in the box.
We've got all of our paperwork, as usual.
Ah, look at this.
This is something I
haven't seen in so long.
A SIM card ejector.
Am I being sarcastic?
That's for you to determine.
Oh, little, teeny, tiny Apple stickers.
And that seems to be all
of our reading material,
something that should with every iPhone,
maybe in the future.
12-watt charging brick.
Lightning cable.
And that, my friends, is
everything that is in the box.
Ah, it's starting up.
Look at this.
Oh, my phone just said,
do you wanna set up your new iPad?
Yes, I do, iPhone, thank you.
You know me so well.
So, the iPad mini has a 7.9-inch screen
and what's great about the new version
of the iPad mini is it also
has the True Tone display.
I'm actually a huge fan of
True Tone display on my iPad
'cause I do a lot of reading
and emails on my iPad,
so it adjusts
to whatever lighting
conditions you're currently in
that's best for your eyes,
so that's something that I do leave on.
I do tend to turn it off
when I'm on my laptop.
Mostly because if I'm doing
any sort of color correction
in my videos or my photos,
I just like knowing that my
screen hasn't changed colors.
But if I'm just reading or
doing anything like that,
I'm a huge fan.
Okay, we're gonna
continue setting this up.
It's official, let's click.
Yes.
With the new A12 Bionic chip,
you're getting a performance boost,
so the performance is
boosted by three times
and the graphics, by nine.
I would like to see a show of hands
of anyone who had watched by
Bob Ross painting tutorial
on the iPad Pro.
If you did and you would like to see me
try to do a Bob Ross
tutorial on this iPad mini,
let me know because this
is really exciting news.
The iPad mini now finally
has Apple Pencil support.
Now, while it doesn't have
Apple Pencil 2 support,
it does support Apple Pencil 1,
and one of the main reasons for that,
the iPad Pro has the magnetic,
flat-edged Apple Pencil,
so that magnetically charges,
magnetically pairs just like this.
That's it, it's magic.
Since this is one of the older designs,
obviously, that Pencil
would not work with this,
which leaves us with the
old style of charging.
You basically take off the
cap of the Apple Pencil
and you just stick it in the bottom.
It's super silly, but I mean,
I feel like at this point,
we've been doing it for so long
that it doesn't even seem strange anymore,
or does it?
Having Apple Pencil support
on these smaller versions
is seriously really incredible.
I just love the use cases of the iPad
that are not your traditional
media viewing devices,
mostly what I use it for.
It's used in healthcare,
it's used in restaurants,
it's used in smart homes.
There are so many other things
outside of just those use cases
that most of us normally use it for.
I'm excited that it does
have Apple Pencil support.
The iPad Air also has
Apple Pencil support.
And it has support for
Bluetooth keyboards.
Did I say support way too many times?
Perhaps I did.
I also have one of the
iPad mini Smart covers.
And what color is this?
Papaya.
Have you guys seen the new
Apple Watch colors for spring?
I have.
They're beautiful.
It's so little.
Like, I just can't get
over how great it is.
Like, it's small.
But in comparison to the
iPhone, this phone is huge.
I can't figure out if this phone is huge
or the iPad is small.
Wow, wow.
Like, I haven't held
one of these in so long
and the screen actually looks really good.
It is just such a perfect,
little, tiny device.
Like, look at you.
Let's open up this Pencil.
Can you believe
I haven't even used a
knife this entire video?
And I don't wanna get up.
Guess I won't use one.
Ooh, am I?
There you go.
Charge up, my friend.
Yep, pair it up.
Look at me taking notes.
Look at my notes.
Only draw with Apple Pencil.
Your fingers will be used
for scrolling instead.
You can change the setting.
Okay.
(chuckles)
I haven't written in cursive in so long.
I'm just like, how do
I make an E and D, S?
Okay, well maybe writing is
not something that I'm good at.
This is the Apple Pencil 1
in comparison to the Apple Pencil 2.
It's a little bit taller, obviously,
'cause it's got this little cap here.
And just some kind of a
flat edge, the magnetic,
to stick to the top.
Let me show you this thing in
comparison to the iPad Pro.
It's just crazy, the size
difference between (chuckles).
Look at this.
This is a house, and
it's also upside down.
- [Justine Voiceover] Hmm,
I can't do that with HomeKit
because I'm not sure
what you mean by upside.
- Shh.
Oh gosh, look at this. (chuckles)
I went on my first
Today at Apple sessions.
If you guys have never gone to one before,
it was so much fun.
Like, I brought a bunch of friends.
We all went and we drew pictures.
Like, we did a Procreate tutorial.
This is definitely not my best work.
I'm not entirely proud of it,
so we're just gonna make that go away.
It really is crazy just
to see these side by side
because the iPad Pro,
because the iPad Pro is really beautiful.
Like, it is a beautiful device.
I know.
My wall is not white.
My desk is brown.
I'm shooting in 24 frames a second.
Take a deep breath.
It's all gonna be okay.
In addition to this newness.
Well, the video looks pretty good.
I'm a little biased because
it's my own video. (chuckles)
Like, I love the iPad.
I love the iPad so much.
Like, just something about
just holding these devices
makes me happy.
Like, they just have
such an incredible feel,
like everything is so intuitive.
And it's so cool to watch
kids use these devices,
and I think that's also something
that this is really primitive for.
I've seen so incredible use cases for this
also in the classroom.
I mean, if you're looking
for something small,
portable, and compact, like, why not?
Perfect size, it now has
Apple Pencil support,
you can connect a Bluetooth keyboard to it
if you choose to do so.
Now when I'm traveling, I
bring my iPad and my MacBook.
This thing is so huge,
especially when I have the
keyboard attached to it.
I mean, I'm essentially traveling
with two laptops at this point.
Just this with the little cover,
I can put this in my yoga
pants pocket, like, easily.
Well, I just wanted to show you guys
a quick little look at the iPad mini.
I'm so excited.
I really wanna do another
Bob Ross tutorial with it.
So, if you haven't seen that video,
I'll put a link in the description
if you wanna watch me draw
a Bob Ross tutorial on my iPad Pro.
I think it'd be really
fun to do one on here.
If you wanna leave me a suggestion
for which Bob Ross tutorial
you would like to see me do,
leave those in the comments below.
And in the meantime,
I'm going to finish setting up this iPad,
get some of my apps ready.
I also wanna test out some of
the augmented reality apps,
so if you have any other suggestions
for ones that I should check out,
also leave those in the comments below.
And I will see you guys very, very soon.
Look at it, it's just so great.
(carefree classical music)